je vais faire un essai sont pas très
bien et quand je me retourne c'est pas
terrible non plus heureusement cale sous
titrage
il faut vraiment que je fasse quelque
chose je crois que le moment est venu
vous avez été nombreux à regretter que
le son ne soit pas de bonne qualité sur
les précédentes capsule avec son micro
ça ne devrait plus se produire alors
c'est à un tout petit micro un micro à
condensateur pour comprendre comment ils
recueillent de son ma voix je vous
propose de commencer par regarder ce
qu'il ya à l'intérieur d'un métro
classique qu'est ce qu'il a dans le
ventre
ici on voit mis une membrane est fixé à
une bobine de fil conducteur qui
coulissent autour d'un aimant maintenant
on va faire une expérience regardez
cette petite installation
quand j'appuie sur l'interrupteur
l'aiguillé de la boussole des vies en
fait la circulation du courant
électrique à l'intérieur du fil
conducteur génère un champ magnétique
auquel l'église de la boussole est
sensible inversement la variation d'un
champ magnétique à proximité d'un fil
conducteur induit un courant électrique
dans ce fil conducteur très concrètement
quand la bobine coulisses autour de
l'aimant la variation du champ
magnétique induit un courant électrique
dans cette bobine
quel rapport avec ma voix
le son c'est de l'air qui vibre l'air
qui nous entoure est constituée de
molécules principalement de la zot et de
l'oxygène 21% de dioxygène 78% de 10 aux
hôtes et 1% de gaz rares la vibration de
mai quand deux local provoquées par le
passage de l'air qui sort de mes poumons
entraîne la détente et la compression
des molécules qui composent l'air ce
mouvement se transmet de proche en
proche jusqu'à nos tympans où seules les
personnes qui nous entourent qui se met
à vibrer les tympans parfois plus quand
la musique est bonne on peut observer ce
phénomène en faisant une petite
expérience celle la gelée déjà fait
c'est même la première expérience que
j'ai faite devant une caméra
j'ai tendu un film alimentaire au dessus
d'un saladier j'ai déposé quelques
grains de sel maintenant ouvrez grand
les yeux
vous avez vu quand je frappe sur le
djembé je fais vibrer la peau qui fait
vibrer l'air cette vibration se transmet
de proche en proche et fait vibrer le
film alimentaire sur lequel les grains
de sel s'agite et mon micro dans tout ça
le son produit par mes cordes vocales ou
par un instrument aussi vibrer la
membrane qui fait bouger et la bobine
autour de l'aimant la variation du champ
magnétique induit donc un courant
électrique à l'intérieur de la bobine un
courant électrique qui modulent
exactement comme ma voix et à partir
duquel on va pouvoir reproduire à
l'autre bout de la chaîne autrement dit
chez vous le son de ma voix
le problème avec le son c'est qu'il se
propage en formant un cône plus il
s'éloigne de la source
- il est concentré c'est pour cette
raison que vous aviez du mal à entendre
quand la petite caméra s'éloigner de moi
ou quand je tournais la tête
le son de ma voix ne faisait pas
suffisamment pression sur son micro
alors que là sous le menton il est aux
premières loges et 4 essentiellement le
son de ma voix est très peu les bruits
ambiants et l'oiseau il va falloir
chanter un peu plus fort maintenant ce
micro est tout petit il est lui aussi
équipé d'une membrane mais il n'y a pas
de bobines ni démons à la place il ya ce
que l'on appelle un condensateur il
s'agit de deux petites plaques
métalliques qui conduisent le courant
électrique et entre lesquelles il y à un
espace minuscule la taille d'un film
alimentaire et condensateurs est
alimenté par une pile
quand je parle le son de ma voix fait
pression sur la membrane qui est aussi
la plaque mobile du condensateur les
plaques se rapproche et le courant
électrique passe plus facilement
au final le courant électrique 20
modules et comme ma voix ça va cette
fois j'ai l'impression qu'on est
vraiment faits pour s'entendre
allez à très bientôt j'ai encore plein
d'histoires à vous raconter terminé et
je coupe le son
[Musique]